maps are an essential component of any
competitive shooter and these combat
zones where players Duke it out need to
be just as balanced as the weapons and
equipment they use for said Duke it to
large open and expansive and some
camping do nothing sniper will go to
town on you forget dead I put them to
can find and enclosed and all it takes
is a knife to really just ruin your day
and every game has a few maps that are
disliked no over the course of counter
strikes history a number of maps have
been immortalized for their tried and
tested ability to be fair enjoyable and
sustainably competitive iconic combat
zones like Inferno this could be a
complete massacre here get right picks
up a prize they're gonna commit that way
through private picks up three in a row
make it fall Freiburg excellent defense
there on banana train and there you go
perfect timing there by apex and now JW
decides to go posting through apex s
though I don't my god they light up
two-for-one say dumb you only JW and of
course does too
but it is too late Garen is gonna be
waiting he Co charges in doesn't check
quads
human reactions and yet for nearly two
decades there has been a map held in far
lesser regard one that has been
demonized above all others for the
anxiety frustration and controversy it
has provoked a battleground that's been
rebalanced and redesigned numerous times
but has remained hated for the majority
of its lifespan of course the map I'm
talking about is nuke
no not nuke town although that map is a
colossal unflushable turd that's right
buddy you show that Turner's boss nuke
is among counterstrikes oldest Maps
first released in November of 1999 it's
been included in the competitive map set
of counter-strike 1.6 source and most
recently global Offensive where it was
remastered and reintroduced to the
competitive rotation in 2016 unlike any
other in the franchise's competitive map
pool nukes bomb sites are stacked
directly on top of one another making it
one of the most structurally unique
environments in counter-strike however
this verticality has given way to
countless issues and confusions for
starters the map has a history of being
a little bit buggy making for some
hilariously broken and entertaining
diffusal x'
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so maybe it wasn't the most broken
thing in gaming ever but it was pretty
close
perhaps nukes most notorious pitfall
stems from the fact that for a long time
CS goes engine source was awful at
registering the verticality of a noises
origin probably in one of the tunnels
above us close to me and for years it
was virtually impossible to tell whether
the terrorists had planted the bomb at
site a or B given that the beeping
noises were spatially indistinguishable
which most likely led to valve giving
the B site an entirely different beeping
sound in September 2018 prior to that
nuke was capable of producing humbling
if not humiliating moments they might
not even be sure and now glaive has
plenty of time to rotate around waiting
for oh no oh my god they go for the B
bomb side they'd they don't know it's
exactly what I was worried about you
don't now glaive knows where they are
look at him he's just posted at the top
of events oh no this is a nightmare
they're trying to get up getting both
the kills completely outsmarting Team
Liquid the quad kill for claim that is
gonna go down in history as one of the
old-time oops as Moses that was that's
rough sound issues aside nukes
vertically oriented objectives make it
one of the hardest Maps for pro players
to navigate since the sites are situated
in painfully close proximity to one
another rotations between them can be
hasty and haphazard taking shocks is
gonna be here but he doesn't have an aid
to stop device from getting the pardons
if the caches are killed down through
that beds very nice push up from shocks
catch his device off-guard and that
leaves just hip Nick's I wouldn't be
surprised if he just tucked tail and ran
away because they can easily diffuse
this bomb he's gonna have very little
say in this round they on it just yet
but they should be soon as if NYX is
taking kills with him he's found another
frag there on the defuse he doesn't
realize there's only one man down on
that B site some is chasing and
dipsticks finds another this is a
10-second defuse and shocks is on the
bomb right now he might just go as if
Nix wins it four kills in that round
another huge clutch it can be really
stressful and you have to master the
rotation and
and take responsibility about who's
gonna and it's you have to make
split-second decision right so I think
that's one of the things being it's it's
so hard to to master four teams
what's more the objectives are
surrounded by a slew of savage sight
lines
agonizing angles and easily punishable
entry ways that make the map an absolute
[ __ ] then I'll take it take it
that force it you see they want to put
the desk right now but Oscar and they're
also chocolate leaf Baker's paper as
well so far funny it's probably the most
difficult map technically speaking and
the city said they requires the most
communication because you constantly
have to move players around you have to
understand rotations really well how to
outplay your teammates and most teams
actually have really bad rotations
they're just really scared to admit it
like there's a lot of chaos constantly
going on which means that you
consistently have to highlight what
special open what things do have to work
out for who's rotating where which is
why it's very difficult to play and only
very few teams last lightly and it's for
these reasons that most professional
teams are quick to veto it
during the map pick/ban phase for years
valve has tried to balance out nuke by
having and removing windows vents and
even entire catwalks and yet as far as
the community is concerned they always
find some way to miss the mark but the
fact that most teams were shying away
from nuke in 2018 inspired one roster to
not only learn it but become certifiably
unbeatable on it
[Applause]
in between February 2018 and the
publishing of this video the Danish
powerhouse that is Astralis have gone an
unbelievable 31 and O on nuke 31 and oh
like what do you even say to that the
funny thing is that lately
their dominance on the map has motivated
other teams to start taking it seriously
as well and on occasion it's even look
like a straw Louis we're going to be
given a taste of their own medicine
Chris J gets a killer 2 SMG that's nice
bonus money for him $1,200 in total and
glaive is the last man standing
Khalil will be worthless ape if he could
find it don't know if he's been spotted
apparently not who was it go for tuesd
it will just be the one and mousesports
have doubled the score of Australis
until they weren't but if Isis hold on
the hot at the same time he's got two
jobs Kody got two jobs and ROPS gets
shot in the head through the vent maybe
even the floor this looked ok for
mousesports now it looks terrible we'll
more work must be done he's got to get
on this bomb plant but obscure his ankle
from heaven Oscar one versus two device
back up top Oscars looking for him both
snipers but only one has got an AWP he
will look for the rotator maybe he heard
cippec's he's got a great angle but the
Crouch pick from zip X will be enough
and the recovery starts for a Stratus
device for the very strong off angle
here this is where the spray comes
through but it won't be good for the
double I thought for sure it was not
oscar has to get the bomb down he knows
he can't claimed is right there they
haven't used this boost so far in the CT
side this could be the surprise that
breaks the back of mousesports be over
here zip X such a strong position to
players to learn three kills oh my god
the smoke afterwards as well as the bomb
being dropped in front of it that is
devastating there's a big GG button
right there device to stop in the open
you never see players playing for this
and he's gonna maybe try to follow them
through the smoke pass he's got
teammates to throw nades in he's in the
top straight through down the stairs
he'll go the spot place is gonna be
separating them to vice going for voice
with the HP now and they are getting
sandwiched oh this is just so horrible
for Mouse paws you can see on their
faces after the first game they felt
like they won that one
only three rounds away and that the
second map as well but that doesn't mean
that these flashes of brilliance aren't
indicative of a changing attitude
towards nuke the view that it isn't an
obstacle to be avoided but want to be
confronted and mastered it takes a huge
depth of knowledge to play the map
because there's so many rotations
constantly on going all the time when
when people get picked off so I think
that's why it seems like astralis who
are the best team right now are so good
on it a lot of people say it's like I
guess you could say a dumb down map but
I think if they complete opposite I
think it takes a high level of knowledge
playing nuke for sure yeah that's it
really you just have to be a team to be
good on new key if you all play
individually you're gonna lose 16 five
every game whether valve intended it or
not the community's perception of nuke
has undergone something of a
transformation it's gone from being one
of counterstrikes
single most attested maps to the one
that professional teams are slowly but
surely striving to prove themselves on
we all know the atomic bomb is very
dangerous since it may be used against
us we must get ready for it
it's kind of beautiful to watch a map
that was shunned for so long become a
benchmark test for the tactical fluency
of professional teams what's less
beautiful though is watching these teams
try and play this map against a straw
Louis since it's starting to look more
and more each day as if the only way to
beat Denmark on nuke is to simply nuke
Denmark wait who wrote this I would
never want to nuke Denmark it seems like
Denmark is actually a pretty great
country and now that I'm thinking about
it this reminds me of a legend about the
Danish flag and about how it fell from
the sky during a battle rapper
man hot-too can find an enclosed just
motorboating oh that's it that's an
attorney you don't hear too much anymore
I used to be like pew just [ __ ] calm
down like where did it even come from
why is it a motor better what he is
motor boating that's and that's that's
gonna be our next video
oh is it yeah it seems like I think
Vince Vaughn would do motorboat you play
the motorboat you've moved a boat inside
of it bet you old sailor you